hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pop goes now we're
gonna roll right back into it not do the
thing that we did cause us to be dead
which is run out of sanity right over
the panic meter is it's just basically
sanity right so it's a mechanic by which
I go crazy or they kill me because I
panic and my brain explodes out of my
ears
so anyway I got I got a few things to
look out for I think I think the the
anima trama with the signs they're
caused by me panicking it's not
necessarily that anything's happening
here right I'll see you then I guess
guess you'll be on your way I'll find
out the answers Dhamma questions later
what what is it what is it I gotta pay
attention to this guy why is he still
there are you sure huh are you still
there what are you doing still there
what are you doing a whole bunch is
still there like how much your style all
he's gone did he go or did he not go I
don't know you did you didn't go didn't
go anywhere Scott dam wrote it oh oh
you're gone now
haven't you play with my emotions like
that shut down invent and heat for some
reason I don't know why I don't know I
need a lot of heat what I do apparently
I don't know I I think he's still there
why am i heating you you I don't know I
don't understand the mechanics is I
don't do that I'll do that do that don't
do that to nobody
I'm a heat we're gas so I don't know
what the noises are so I'm gonna I'm
gonna hold off on the heat because I
don't know if I'm doing anything
detrimental to myself man this guy's
this guy's more persistent about 3d
printing this shadow body and if he gets
that shadow Bonnie he's gonna be on my
butt in a second or two so
got to do this I heard it but Lulu I
don't know what the Badou loop is Badou
oh what the [ __ ] are you
oh I'm in trouble
Oh Oh
no heat do I need heat is that what I
need I think you go you should panic
really should I I think I'm already in
trouble why was that thought I saw
something okay I don't know what's going
on here cuz that was weird that was
rather peculiar I don't know what I just
saw
the Hecky heck is going hacking on here
whoa anybody boom oh there you are okay
okay there you are you shut down don't
know what the heap do I don't know what
noises I'm listening out for oh you're
still there okay alright okay pop goes
the weasel up goes the market moving
squeezes my brains out how'd you get a
piece Oh how'd you break off a piece of
that [ __ ] I'll freak you dude
[Music]
already moved
he's a mobile little son of weed there
he is almost hard to see you not quite
as hard as me seeing me what are you two
gonna do back there I know that you have
woo
I know that you two have something to do
with all this but I don't know what the
[ __ ] he was right there it was right
there who's right there is right there
where to go where to go goddamnit last
one
alright everything's hunky Dickie let me
just get my ass out of my ass I should
be fine to get through this
well panic-inducing it's a little when I
don't know the goddamn mechanics of you
so where did that [ __ ] come from
where does the mechanical [ __ ]
[ __ ] go what was that
why do I need to check these up it's
more uh more and more noises app wait a
minute there you are
no that's the day seems to be more
noises wait a minute where are you going
that's bad where's the staff room how do
I shouldn't you get some colors in you
[ __ ] ah no don't go in the van no no no
no hate I don't I think I don't know I'm
dead aren't I I'm I don't know how to
beat this from me oh you stop that so
they're good you are too late I don't
know am I really
is it really too late hey I've got heat
for you his name is fritz I don't care I
am panicking aah aah it's hard to see
when I'm panicking that all this panic
juice shooting out of my eyes I'm gonna
heat a friend again I think yeah they
went in the van they're in the they're
in the vent they're not they didn't just
go in the vent area in the vents
I am in the fork I'm in the pong zone
I'm in the zone of bone
wait I'm gonna die sir I didn't mean to
do that but I'll heat it up anyway if
I'm just gonna make [ __ ] mistakes I
might as well make them all another
piece of puzzle I don't know how to get
another piece of the puzzle what I hate
song
oh no you don't oh I think I'm doing the
right thing and I'm not under cent sure
but I think I am if I'm not then I'm
gonna die that's just along in the tour
of it I'm gonna die okay oh I see you oh
I caught you question mark I hated you
oh I'm here great you're here oh give a
round of applause to miss her here man
what was all that what are you doing out
there
where are you up there there don't make
no sense
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] so they're like at the far
vent is that what that thing is and they
got to make their all the way to me is
that is that what they do is that the
dude that they are is that the do some
would do they cause it's not what did
they do then screwed I don't like it
well okay I guess I'm just relaxed
instantaneously I go from a full not
relaxed to a full relaxed
oh they're not there anymore they're
there I need to give them some heed but
I [ __ ] it oh you're not gonna [ __ ] it
is that what you're making that shadow
Bonnie some kind of weirdo real-life
doll not into that heat take my heat I'm
gonna banish you with the power of ye I
think I don't know kind of grasping
straws right now colours this in a
little pop in a blink easy for ya good
bad give me a review on Yelp
oh you'll kill me huh okay great well
whatever man well that seems to have
stopped them pretty good pretty sure
anyway so now it's just about bouncing
between the two of them
and then I'm good right that's all there
is then I think I'm in the golden Freddy
and whatever the hell that anima trauma
was 5:00 a.m. which bodes well for me so
what would I do if I'd be Bubber Knox
like straight up a million times through
and through they're still there okay
they're nice and toasty that it's a real
toasty really toasty feel really toasty
so you stay here you or kitties you
don't stay there you don't stay there
don't stay there and finish that I don't
do that that's not what you do
you're still there you can heat oink
oink oink oink oink and uh I don't know
I guess I must be oh stop that
what was that you hear that heard that
like I don't like he cranky I don't like
you so far so good
[Music]
are you you sack a shoot won't stab you
with something I don't know what I'm
gonna stab you okay anyway so I got that
let's see what's going on in the next
one I have a funny feeling but I'm not
exactly you know a willing participant
in this experiment of ours Oh
what sword deep what are you oh you know
what you are I don't want to know you
some kind of squirrel it's all the other
five nights at Freddy's fan games in one
horrible hellhole
why are we in a hellhole with veins and
[ __ ] and trash and why was Balloon Boy
hooked up to that thing from guardians
of the galaxy to you know having his
soul all sucked out and the such not as
that I'm trying to take a different path
here maybe it's gonna lead to different
results that oh that Fox ears that
mangle mangles boy let me get all
mangled
I can't go this way burn ladies oh I'm
just gonna don't like that sound that's
an uncomfortable sound what else is here
is there just a whole bunch of other
stuff waiting for me in the darkness I
don't know it's kind of a maze Oh a
cupcake well this is where chicas grave
is but is it just like a it's like a
grave for all of them we're not really a
grave I guess if they're all trapped and
part of the machine as they are all
machines anyway so what does it matter
you could not do that in my ear you
could not raise the base up please oh
that's a microphone can I go this way
Freddy Fred boy Fred boy Freddy
Freddy's time hat well that spells bad
Freddy are you hooked up to a giant
tentacle machine I'm gonna close my eyes
and I'm gonna walk in that room and if
your intended goals I'm gonna judge
y'all I'm judging you okay that's weird
Oh
third night with a bang all right let's
get into this I don't know what new
mechanic I'm gonna have to deal with but
you're gonna tell me what it is and I'm
gonna die boggle like I always do
remember colors call the Badger that
doesn't make any goddamn sense
remember colors call the Badger what
does that even mean
what do you even mean who are you Who am
I they're already gone Frick I'll just
pick up the phone
I've been doing
[Music]
No
oh oh that's moving banter oh that's no
good I don't know about that I don't
know what to do
I'm gonna die oh you're really close we
were really close I don't know how to
get rid of you I'm gonna die it's right
behind me oh boy here we go yes fine
where'd he go all right it's gone well
I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna
be dead oh well [ __ ] what is that even
mean go wipe well I'm I'm I'm well and
thoroughly boned I'm dead well happens
obvious I'm dying I'm dead obviously and
what happened I don't know what happened
I don't know anyway that's all for this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm gonna continue this it's
getting tough tough panic-inducing all
the above
welcome to weasel we're indeed so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you think down the comments
below
now as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]